the jurgen experience
you're going to use them i'll definitely
use them all right i like candles
those are good too and they're soy too
they're soy
yeah they're hand poured and you can
have them back i'm not in this i don't
do anything with soy
it's a candle man don't disrespect that
people one day
people get mad at soy soy is like a
political
fruit or a vegetable is it yeah yeah
yeah
people call you a soy boy if you're a
republican people call uh
weak men soy boys that's like a it's an
insult
i never knew that soy is one of the rare
foods that's actually attached to being
a [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] food yeah like if you're
if you're a guy who's really in the soy
and this is not my perspective this is
just i just think it's a [ __ ]
it's a plant it doesn't matter to me
right it's uh isn't that edamame isn't
that soy
like when you have edamame at a japanese
restaurant isn't it soy
yes yeah is that is that the case jamie
the first time i ever tried edamame
i was so ghetto did you use the whole
thing yeah
and i was like i was like my throat was
killing me so the best part is the
outside
i didn't know anything about it salt and
everything in the outside the sea salt
yeah some
sea salt you have a bowl of just edamame
it takes away from it you wouldn't even
want it it's the whole process
yeah the whole process of like ripping a
sleeve edamame beans are whole
immature soybeans sometimes referred to
as vegetable
vegetable type soybeans they're green
and different color from regular
soybeans which are typically light brown
tan or beige
yeah so it's the soy i like edamame i
don't mind soy but a lot of people think
of soy
as being like a [ __ ] food i never knew
that i thought it was a healthy
i mean i knew that it was not the most
masculine food but i thought it was like
you stepped your game up when you
entered the edamame lane it's like oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ] eat edamame
i think there's a reason i think soy
lowers your testosterone i think
there's like estrogen yeah yeah soy
isoflavones can
produce estrogen-like activity in the
body mimicking the effects of natural
estrogen
yeah but i think you can grow titties
off of soy not
quite but it might feminize you it might
feminize you
plants plants affect your your hormone
production
do you know they they actually develop
testosterone like
synthetic testosterone from wild yams
like plants yeah
from wild yellow yams yeah that's how
they that's how uh
they develop some um artificial
testosterone or
exogenous testosterone i always think
that that would be part of the whole
siteless um cialis and
blue pill errors that's a different
thing though that's just blood flow
that's nitrous
oxide so why is nobody promoting wow
nitrous oxide nitrous uh
what is it what is it nitric nitric
oxide
um that's like no explode all those pump
things you do when you want to get
jacked right lifting weights a lot of
those
those uh supplements they mimic the same
sort of effect just not the same degree
as like finasteride like ad uh like uh
viagra and cialis and [ __ ] like that
but they don't they don't make you have
more testosterone with these
like soybeans and i i think really for
it to affect your hormones
i think it's just like it can it's a fat
it's a possibility
like chemically but in order to actually
do it i think you'd have to eat some
[ __ ] preposterous number of soybeans
i don't think it's like something people
really have to worry about no i don't
think it's anything
anybody really has to worry about but i
think it's just a stereotype
i didn't even know that the thing was
just hard for me i didn't even know the
stereotype
yeah they called it the soy boys i
didn't know that i thought it was like a
uh
like you you're evolving as a foodie you
know like the first time i had
i was like oh [ __ ] y'all [ __ ] don't
know about the edamames
because i was introducing somebody else
to it but i didn't know that it
symbolized being a [ __ ]
it doesn't it's silly it's people are
silly it tastes
good yeah adam may taste good if they do
it right
put a little chili powder and salt on
the outside
i like it with just sea salt episodes of
the joe rogan experience are now
free on spotify that's right they're
free
from september 1st to december 1st
they're going to be available everywhere
but after december 1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love